Welcome to your second drink of stress relief part two.
Stanley is back to work after his heart attack,
and there was a storyline that would have kicked off this episode
that was added back to the superfan episode that's really fun.
Okay, people are sort of making a fuss over Stanley.
You know, they're hovering over him.
Phyllis has brought him lunch, and it's driving Stanley crazy.
Let's listen.
欢迎来到“压力缓解”第二部分的第二杯饮品。斯坦利心脏病发作后回到了工作岗位，这一集原本有一个开场情节，后来被加回了超级粉丝版，非常有趣。好吧，大家都在为斯坦利小题大做。你知道，他们都在他身边转悠。菲利斯给他带了午餐，这让斯坦利快疯了。我们来听听。
I brought you some lunch, Stanley.
You did?
Thank you.
What was that?
It's three bean salad, cashier.
in Brussels sprouts.
Oh.
If you don't like it, you don't have to eat it.
我给你带了午餐，斯坦利。真的吗？谢谢。那是什么？是三豆沙拉，收银员。还有抱子甘蓝。哦。如果你不喜欢，你不必吃它。
No, I appreciate it.
Wow.
You must be really freaked out to eat that.
Long you have to live anyway.
Andy, please.
Hey, well, what's going on?
Stanley, you okay?
I'm fine.
不，我很感激。哇。你一定是被吓坏了才会吃那个。反正你也没几天好活了。安迪，拜托。嘿，好吧，怎么了？斯坦利，你还好吗？我很好。
God.
Phil said you take off your shoe.
It's Stanley's lunch.
Oh, no wonder you're dying.
If you'll excuse me.
Yep.
Ready to go to the bathroom?
I am not going to the bathroom with you. Please stop trying to help me.
天哪。菲尔说你脱了鞋。那是斯坦利的午餐。哦，难怪你要死了。失陪了。是的。准备去洗手间了吗？我才不要跟你一起去洗手间。请停止试图帮助我。
Stanley, we just want you to get better.
How can I get better? Since this happened, I haven't had a single moment where I haven't been
reminded that I'm sick and probably going to die in this office. Not one single moment.
They're just like all on top of him. They will not let him have a moment's piece.
And they keep reminding him of everything. So it was after this exchange that Michael gets the idea
that he needs to do a roast for his employees.
Yes.
He needs to lighten the mood.
斯坦利，我们只是想让你好起来。我怎么能好起来？自从这件事发生后，我没有一刻不被提醒我生病了，而且很可能会死在这个办公室里。一刻都没有。他们就像全都压在他身上。他们不让他有片刻安宁。而且他们不断提醒他所有的事情。所以就是在这次交流之后，迈克尔想到了他需要为员工举办一场吐槽大会。是的。他需要缓和一下气氛。
And what better way than to have a roast?
So you know the way this episode would have started, lady, is like Michael and Dwight,
they're commiserating in Michael's office.
Well, the superfan episode has a tiny extension to that scene.
Dwight is going to hand Michael a pen and ask him to sign something.
It's the thing where, like, Dwight's getting everybody.
acknowledgement of his apology for setting the fire drill.
And in the original episode, it just sort of cuts off right there.
还有什么比举办一场吐槽大会更好的方式呢？所以你知道这一集原本是怎么开始的吗，女士，就像迈克尔和德怀特在迈克尔的办公室里同病相怜。好吧，超级粉丝版对那个场景有一个小小的扩展。德怀特要递给迈克尔一支笔，让他签个名。就是那种德怀特让每个人都承认他为火灾演习道歉的事情。在原版剧集中，就在那里切断了。
Like Dwight, hands him a pen and Michael signs it.
But there's a little bit more, and it cracked me up, and I think we need to hear it.
I don't get it.
Do I stress you out?
Nothing stresses me out, except having to seek the approval of my inferiors.
Oh.
Speaking of which.
Dwight, I am a good person
就像德怀特递给他一支笔，迈克尔签了名。但还有一点点内容，这让我笑喷了，我觉得我们需要听听。我不明白。我让你感到压力了吗？没有什么让我感到压力，除了必须寻求下属的认可。哦。说到这个。德怀特，我是个好人。
I'm a good person
You are
You're a good person
I'm a good person
Why can't they just see that
You just put my pen in your pocket
No, I didn't
I own all the pens in this place
我是个好人。你是。你是个好人。我是个好人。为什么他们就是看不出来呢？你刚才把我的笔放进你的口袋里了。不，我没有。这个地方所有的笔都是我的。
No, I brought that in from home
It says Washington Mutual on it has a little piece of chain
Okay
Can
Empty your pockets
Meeting is over Dwight
Jerk
You're a jerk
不，那是我从家里带来的。上面写着华盛顿互惠银行，还有一小段链子。好吧。可以清空你的口袋。会议结束了，德怀特。混蛋。你是个混蛋。
That is the stuff I love the most. I'm so sad. That wasn't in the original. I'm so glad it's back in. Lady, it's amazing. As soon as he signs the clipboard, he puts the pen in his pocket. And Dwight calls him out. And it's hilarious because when he says, it says Washington Mutual has a little piece of chain. Now you know Dwight stole it from the bank. Michael's stealing it from Dwight. Dwight probably popped it off the chain at the bank.
counter. Yes. Oh my gosh. That is too funny. I loved it. Okay, well, we also got this letter from
Liz M from Philly, who says, just listen to stress relief, please in the second drink,
translate Oscar's Roast. So in our original breakdown, we played the extended version of
Oscars Roast. It starts in English and then goes into Spanish, but we did not translate his roast.
Why don't we hear it again just to refresh everyone's memory?
And then I'll tell you what it says.
He thinks balancing a checkbook is putting a checkbook on his nose and shouting,
那是我最喜欢的内容。我太难过了。那不在原版里。我很高兴它又回来了。女士，这太神奇了。他一签完剪贴板，就把笔放进了口袋。德怀特揭穿了他。这太搞笑了，因为当他说“上面写着华盛顿互惠银行，还有一小段链子”时。现在你知道德怀特是从银行偷来的。迈克尔是从德怀特那里偷来的。德怀特可能是在银行柜台把链子弄断的。是的。天哪。这太有趣了。我喜欢它。好吧，我们还收到了来自费城利兹·M的这封信，她说，请听压力缓解，在第二杯饮品中，翻译奥斯卡的吐槽。所以在我们最初的解析中，我们播放了奥斯卡吐槽的加长版。它以英语开始，然后转为西班牙语，但我们没有翻译他的吐槽。我们为什么不重听一遍来唤起大家的记忆呢？然后我会告诉你它说了什么。他认为平衡支票簿就是把支票簿放在鼻子上大喊，
Look at me!
Me!
Okay, what is he saying, lady?
For you.
For a Tis.
Okay, what is he saying, lady?
So here's the thing.
Liz, he is talking way too fast for me.
看着我！我！好吧，他在说什么，女士？为你。为了一个蒂斯。好吧，他在说什么，女士？事情是这样的。利兹，他说话对我来说太快了。
The only part I could understand was pat-a-ti, pat-ti.
But I went online, and according to the folks on the Internet,
who were able to translate it, here's what Oscar is saying.
They give you kind of two versions.
Quote, I get an ulcer every time I wake up and have to come to work for you, for you.
Or optionally, you give me an ulcer every time I wake up and I have to come work for you, for you.
So he gets an ulcer from Michael.
Yep.
我唯一能听懂的部分是“pat-a-ti, pat-ti”。但我上网查了，根据互联网上那些能够翻译它的人的说法，奥斯卡说的是这些。他们给了你两种版本。引用：“我每次醒来不得不为你工作时都会得溃疡，为你。”或者可选地，“你每次让我醒来不得不为你工作时都让我得溃疡，为你。”所以他因为迈克尔得了溃疡。是的。
Well, speaking of the roast, in our breakdown, we mentioned that the candy bag for the roast was 200.
hundred and seven pages. That's bonkers. Lady, I think we need an episode of Office Lady 6.0
called Boom Roasted, where we dig into some of those alts. That would be a really fun.
All right. Well, we'll get started on that. And for now, please enjoy your second drink of
stress relief part two. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together.
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you.
week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
好吧，说到吐槽大会，在我们的解析中，我们提到吐槽大会的糖果袋有207页。这太疯狂了。女士，我觉得我们需要一集名为“砰，被吐槽了”的《办公室女士》6.0，深入挖掘其中一些备选内容。那会非常有趣。好吧。好吧，我们会开始做那个。现在，请享受你的第二杯“压力缓解”第二部分。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Welcome, welcome.
It's stress relief, part two.
Part two.
Oh, is that?
We're going to be very refined today.
Part dos.
Oh, third language.
Indonesian.
欢迎，欢迎。这是“压力缓解”，第二部分。第二部分。哦，是吗？我们今天会非常文雅。第二部分（西班牙语）。哦，第三种语言。印尼语。
Part doa.
We are a classy show.
This is season five, episode 15.
Written by Paul Lieberstein, directed by Jeffrey Blitz.
Let me give you a summary.
Last week, if you remember, Dwight took matters into his own hands when his co-workers failed to pay attention to his fire safety seminar.
He did a big fire drill.
He, like, trapped us in a burning building.
第二部分（印尼语）。我们是一个高雅的节目。这是第五季第15集。由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，杰弗里·布里茨导演。让我给你一个总结。上周，如果你还记得，德怀特在同事们不注意他的消防安全研讨会时采取了行动。他进行了一次大型火灾演习。他把我们困在了一栋着火的建筑里。
He did.
Stanley had a heart attack.
Dwight was in hot water with corporate.
We have that.
Right.
This week, Michael learned that he was the source.
of Stanley's stress, not Dwight, not the fire drill. And so he thinks the best thing to do
is to throw a roast. Like an old school roast, right? For himself. Right? Yes. Yeah.
他确实做了。斯坦利心脏病发作了。德怀特在公司惹上了麻烦。我们有那个。对。这周，迈克尔了解到他是斯坦利压力的来源，不是德怀特，不是火灾演习。所以他认为最好的办法是举办一场吐槽大会。就像老派的吐槽大会，对吧？为他自己。对吧？是的。是的。
Where we all roast him until jokes at his expense. And we're laughing. Yeah, drinking. Like Dean Martin.
Yeah. This is Friars Club. This is going to be his comic relief moment. Meanwhile, Jim is still
embroiled in these marital issues that Pam's parents are having. Pam's dad has been staying with Jim and Pam.
And Pam, at the end of the last episode, said, Jim, will you talk to my dad?
Oh, Pam. Find out what's going on. That's the worst. Like, Pam, will you go talk to my parents?
Yeah. I can't do it. You go to it. I cannot imagine asking Lee to go talk to my parents about their marriage.
Oh, my Lord. Do you imagine?
Imagine?
我们都在吐槽他，直到拿他的开销开玩笑。我们在笑。是的，喝酒。就像迪恩·马丁。是的。这是弗莱尔斯俱乐部。这将是他喜剧缓解的时刻。与此同时，吉姆仍然卷入了帕姆父母的婚姻问题中。帕姆的父亲一直和吉姆与帕姆住在一起。帕姆在上一集结尾说，吉姆，你能和我爸爸谈谈吗？哦，帕姆。找出发生了什么。那是最糟糕的。就像，帕姆，你能去和我父母谈谈吗？是的。我做不到。你去吧。我无法想象让李去和我父母谈论他们的婚姻。哦，天哪。你能想象吗？想象？
No.
That'd be so weird.
I know.
Incidentally, my dad's name is Jim.
Does the world know that?
Because is someone out there right now being like, what?
And my brother-in-law's name is Dwight.
Yes.
不。那太奇怪了。我知道。顺便说一句，我爸爸的名字叫吉姆。全世界都知道吗？因为现在外面有人在想，什么？我姐夫的名字叫德怀特。是的。
Do you guys know this?
And my niece's name is Cece.
And her best friend is named Angela.
What's going on?
I think we mentioned this fact in an earlier podcast, but it is interesting.
All right.
Also, last week, I want to remind everyone that the seven.
episode played after the Super Bowl, it was a super big deal.
你们知道吗？我侄女的名字叫西西。她最好的朋友叫安吉拉。怎么回事？我想我们在之前的播客中提到过这个事实，但这很有趣。好吧。另外，上周，我想提醒大家，这一集是在超级碗之后播放的，这是一件超级大的事情。
Mm-hmm.
And the network wanted big name stars, and our show was like, hey, no, we don't do that,
not at this moment.
And so we had this whole little movie playing out.
So that's going on, too.
Yeah, Jim and Pam and Andy are watching this pirated movie that stars Jack Black, Jessica
Alba, and Cloris Leachman.
What happening?
嗯哼。电视网想要大牌明星，而我们的节目说，嘿，不，我们不那样做，至少现在不。所以我们有整部小电影在播放。所以那也在进行中。是的，吉姆、帕姆和安迪正在看这部由杰克·布莱克、杰西卡·阿尔芭和克洛里斯·利奇曼主演的盗版电影。发生了什么？
I think we caught you up.
Yeah, you're caught up.
Fast fact number one, Jeff Blitz, won.
an Emmy for directing this episode.
Yeah.
And he deserves it.
He does.
This was complicated.
我想我们让你赶上了。是的，你赶上了。第一个速记事实，杰夫·布里茨凭借执导这一集赢得了艾美奖。是的。他当之无愧。他确实。这很复杂。
So Jeff Blitz has been on our show before.
We love him.
I mean, I literally love Jeff Blit.
I know.
I love him as a human being.
I love him as a director.
I would also like you to know that our editors, Dean Holland and Dave Rogers, were also nominated
for an Emmy for this episode.
所以杰夫·布里茨之前来过我们的节目。我们爱他。我的意思是，我真的爱杰夫·布里茨。我知道。我爱他作为一个人的样子。我爱他作为一个导演的样子。我还想让你知道，我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德和戴夫·罗杰斯也凭借这一集获得了艾美奖提名。
They deserve it.
Dean edited the first half of the episode with the whole fire drum.
and Dave edited the second with The Roast, which is what we will be talking about today.
Fast fact number two, we had a fan question about the Roast.
Okay.
Jessica Kay and Claire R asked, who wrote the jokes for Michael's Roast?
Did the cast help?
Was it the writers?
他们当之无愧。迪恩剪辑了这一集的前半部分，也就是整个火灾演习，戴夫剪辑了后半部分，也就是吐槽大会，这就是我们今天要谈论的内容。第二个速记事实，我们有一个关于吐槽大会的粉丝问题。好的。杰西卡·K和克莱尔·R问，谁为迈克尔的吐槽大会写了笑话？演员们帮忙了吗？是编剧吗？
Was any of it improvised?
Short answer is the Roast was totally scripted.
Yeah.
We as actors did not participate in writing these jokes.
No, no, no.
These were all written.
All written.
And I found out who pitched this part of the story, the idea of the roast.
其中有即兴创作吗？简短的回答是，吐槽大会完全是剧本化的。是的。我们作为演员没有参与编写这些笑话。不，不，不。这些都是写好的。全都是写好的。我发现了是谁提出了故事的这一部分，即吐槽大会的想法。
Who?
It is none other than the man behind Princess Unicorn, Halstead Sullivan.
Oh, really?
Hallstead told me that they had the CPR storyline for the first half of the episode,
and they needed something for the second half.
So he told the writer's room that when he was growing up in Atlanta,
his father was president of a medical school.
And every year, the medical students would put on a show.
谁？正是“独角兽公主”背后的男人，霍尔斯特德·沙利文。哦，真的吗？霍尔斯特德告诉我，他们有这一集前半部分的CPR故事情节，他们需要后半部分的内容。所以他告诉编剧室，当他在亚特兰大长大时，他的父亲是一所医学院的院长。每年，医学生都会表演一场节目。
And it was kind of like a Folly's show.
And they would do skits where they imitated their professors.
He said the audience loved it.
The professors not so much.
Well, you know, I think Michael thinks everyone doesn't like me because I'm this jerk.
They think I'm a jerk boss, right?
Yeah.
So here's your chance, guys.
这有点像滑稽秀。他们会表演模仿教授的小品。他说观众很喜欢。教授们就不那么喜欢了。好吧，你知道，我认为迈克尔觉得每个人都不喜欢我，因为我是个混蛋。他们觉得我是个混蛋老板，对吧？是的。所以这是你们的机会，伙计们。
Have at it.
you know, roast me, say whatever you want.
I love that he's like, make fun of, you know, how great I look in shoulder pads or...
Also, traditionally, roasting kind of started with the Friars Club, I believe.
And it was a great honor to be the person being roasted.
Oh, yeah.
It meant something.
It was a position of status.
尽管来吧。你知道，吐槽我，说任何你想说的话。我喜欢他那种，拿我穿垫肩的样子有多棒开玩笑，或者……此外，传统上，吐槽大会始于弗莱尔斯俱乐部，我相信。成为被吐槽的人是一种巨大的荣誉。哦，是的。它意味着什么。这是一种地位的象征。
And so I think that's another thing that is playing off Michael right now, which is that he's going to be an honoree.
Yeah.
This is a big deal.
You guys are so lucky you get to roast me.
Speaking of roasts, you know, Comedy Central has kind of taken over where the Friars Club left off.
And they do these roasts of people every year.
The Bruce Willis roast is real good.
But in particular, Ed Norton roasts Bruce Willis.
所以我认为这是迈克尔现在正在玩的另一件事，那就是他将成为受邀嘉宾。是的。这是一件大事。你们真幸运能吐槽我。说到吐槽，你知道，喜剧中心已经接手了弗莱尔斯俱乐部留下的工作。他们每年都会举办这些吐槽大会。布鲁斯·威利斯的吐槽大会非常好。但特别是，艾德·诺顿吐槽布鲁斯·威利斯。
I was like rolling tears, streaming down my face.
It is such a good roast.
When we were prepping this episode, it came to my mind.
I went back and I watched it twice.
I wish I could play it.
It's way too long.
Oh, I want to see it.
I want to see it.
我当时泪流满面。那真是一场精彩的吐槽。当我们准备这一集时，我想到了它。我回去看了两遍。我真希望我能播放它。它太长了。哦，我想看。我想看。
Check it out.
The first time I saw Amy Schumer was on a Comedy Central roast and she was so funny.
And there were a few dudes that were like kind of thrown her shade and she just decimated them.
Wow.
All right.
Moving along, fast fact number three, Cloris Leachman.
Chloris freaking Leachman.
We told you there's this mini movie and Cloris Leachman is one of the stars.
去看看吧。我第一次看到艾米·舒默是在喜剧中心的吐槽大会上，她太搞笑了。有几个家伙有点在贬低她，她直接把他们摧毁了。哇。好吧，继续前进，第三个速记事实，克洛里斯·利奇曼。克洛里斯·该死的·利奇曼。我们告诉过你有一个迷你电影，克洛里斯·利奇曼是主演之一。
she kills it in this mini-mov.
Legend, legend.
I mean, incredible, I needed to do a little breakdown of Cloris Leachman.
Here it is.
Clorice Leachman was born in Des Moines, Iowa, Midwesterner.
Did not know that.
As a child, she performed at the Des Moines Little Theater.
Then she won a special scholarship to study broadcast drama at Northwestern.
她在迷你电影里表现得太棒了。传奇，传奇。我的意思是，不可思议，我需要对克洛里斯·利奇曼做一个小小的解析。在这里。克洛里斯·利奇曼出生在爱荷华州得梅因，中西部人。不知道这一点。小时候，她在得梅因小剧院表演。然后她赢得了特别奖学金，在西北大学学习广播戏剧。
She stayed there for a while, but then she returned to Des Moines to finish high school.
Then she returned to Northwestern with a theater scholarship this time.
But she dropped out again to enter a beauty contest.
This beauty contest?
Mm-hmm.
She eventually made her way to the 1946 Miss America pageant.
What?
She was in the Miss America page.
她在那里待了一段时间，但后来她回到得梅因完成了高中学业。然后她这次带着戏剧奖学金回到了西北大学。但她又退学去参加选美比赛了。这个选美比赛？嗯哼。她最终参加了1946年的美国小姐选美大赛。什么？她参加了美国小姐选美大赛。
For Iowa?
I guess for Iowa.
Wow.
I'm not sure.
Eventually she moved to New York.
She studied at the actor's studio.
That's a big deal.
acting school guys. Then she made her Broadway debut in 1948 in a production called Sundown Beach.
代表爱荷华州？我想是代表爱荷华州。哇。我不确定。最终她搬到了纽约。她在演员工作室学习。那是一件大事。表演学校，伙计们。然后她在1948年的一部名为《日落海滩》的作品中首次亮相百老汇。
She became a household name when she was cast as Phyllis Lindstrom on the Mary Tyler Moore show.
And then she had her own spin-off show, Phyllis. She won a best-supporting Oscar for Peter Bogdanovich's
The Last Picture Show, Angela. Which was written by Larry McMurtry, who is from my hometown of Archer City, Texas, and they filmed it.
in Archer City.
And it was written by, you know, Larry never officially claimed it, but folks in Archer City.
So they'd be like, were you so-and-so?
Did you sleep with that person?
What's happening?
当她在《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》中饰演菲利斯·林德斯特罗姆时，她成为了家喻户晓的名字。然后她有了自己的衍生剧《菲利斯》。她凭借彼得·博格丹诺维奇的《最后一场电影》获得了奥斯卡最佳女配角奖，安吉拉。这部电影是由拉里·麦克默特里编剧的，他来自我的家乡德克萨斯州阿彻城，他们就在阿彻城拍摄的。而且它是由，你知道，拉里从未正式承认过，但阿彻城的人们。所以他们会说，你是某某吗？你和那个人睡过吗？发生了什么？
Oh, so people were like trying to figure out who everybody was.
Yeah.
Which person is Sybil Shepard?
Which person is Flores Leachman?
Yeah, exactly.
And Larry said it was inspired by, you know.
Mm-hmm.
哦，所以人们就像在试图弄清楚每个人是谁。是的。是的。哪个人是西比尔·谢泼德？哪个人是克洛里斯·利奇曼？是的，完全正确。拉里说它是受，你知道，启发的。嗯哼。
I don't know.
I feel like there's some woman named Doris, who knows.
She's like it was me.
Jenna, I actually read the last picture show a few years after I had left Archer City and I was in college.
I was like, you know what?
This is a book about my hometown.
I want to read it's so great.
嗯哼。我不知道。我觉得有个叫多丽丝的女人，谁知道呢。她就像是我。珍娜，我实际上是在离开阿彻城几年后，在大学里读了《最后一场电影》。我想，你知道吗？这是一本关于我家乡的书。我想读它，太棒了。
It's a great read.
It's a great book and a great movie is what you're saying.
Yeah.
So I'm saying don't skip the book on this one, guys.
Over the course of her career, she won a total of eight Emmys for both drama and comedy, by the way.
She won a daytime Emmy.
She won a Golden Globe Award.
and in 2008, at the age of 82, she was a contestant on season 7 of Dancing with the Stars.
这是一本很棒的书，也是一部很棒的电影，你是这个意思。是的。所以我说不要错过这本书，伙计们。在她的职业生涯中，她总共赢得了八项艾美奖，顺便说一句，涵盖了戏剧和喜剧。她赢得了日间艾美奖。她赢得了金球奖。2008年，82岁时，她是《与星共舞》第七季的参赛者。
She was the oldest contestant to ever dance on Dancing with the Stars.
And she was inducted into the Television Academy Hall of Fame in 2011.
I mean, the legacy of this woman.
Sadly, she passed away in 2021 at the age of 94.
And she was on our show.
I know.
This legend.
Legend, amazing woman.
她是《与星共舞》历史上最年长的参赛者。她于2011年入选电视学院名人堂。我的意思是，这个女人的遗产。可悲的是，她于2021年去世，享年94岁。她曾出现在我们的节目中。我知道。这位传奇。传奇，了不起的女人。
Jenna, did you know I got to spend a little bit of time with Cloris?
Yes.
Now, not during this episode.
Not during this episode.
Because none of us met these guys during this episode.
No, we didn't film when they were there, which was a bummer.
But I ended up co-presenting an award at the 2012 Genesis Awards with Cloris.
We were co-presenters.
珍娜，你知道我曾和克洛里斯待过一小会儿吗？是的。现在，不是在这一集期间。不是在这一集期间。因为我们没有人在这集期间见过这些人。不，他们在那儿的时候我们没拍，这很遗憾。但我最终在2012年的创世纪奖上和克洛里斯一起颁奖。我们是共同颁奖人。
Oh, my gosh.
We had to hang out backstage.
I met her daughter, Dinah, who.
is lovely. They were the cutest mother-daughter duo. And then Clarice and I went out on stage together.
We presented this award. And she truly was such a hoot. She, I think, was at the age in her life and
in her career where she gave, as the kids say zero Fs. Uh-huh. And then I would run into her and
her daughter at different events. And we would say hi because we had formed this little connection.
Yeah. But anyway, she was just so fun and so full of life. And I'm so glad.
哦，天哪。我们不得不在后台闲逛。我见到了她的女儿黛娜，她很可爱。她们是这对最可爱的母女组合。然后克洛里斯和我一起走上舞台。我们颁发了这个奖项。她确实是一个很有趣的人。我想，她当时处于人生和职业生涯的那个阶段，正如孩子们所说的，她完全不在乎了。嗯哼。然后我会在不同的活动中遇到她和她的女儿。我们会打招呼，因为我们建立了这种小小的联系。是的。但无论如何，她就是那么有趣，那么充满活力。我很高兴。
I just got to just interact with her those few times.
Yeah, I love that story, Ang.
Why don't we take a break and we'll come back and break down this episode.
Okay, great.
We start this episode with Pam being kind of upset.
She's just gotten off the phone with her mom.
And she's going to go find Jim and say, hey, what did you say to my dad?
Yeah, her idea of having Jim talked to her dad did not go well.
我只是在那几次互动中和她接触过。是的，我喜欢那个故事，安吉。我们为什么不休息一下，回来解析这一集。好的，太棒了。我们以帕姆有点心烦意乱开始这一集。她刚和她妈妈通完电话。她要去找吉姆说，嘿，你对我爸爸说了什么？是的，她让吉姆和她爸爸谈谈的想法并没有奏效。
Apparently her dad is now looking for an apartment and the divorce is on.
It's happening.
Pam gets really worried. She has this talking head where she says, what could Jim have said to make my dad want to leave my mom? And at what point in their marriage is Jim going to say this to her? She's spiraling. I think she's spiraling. Yeah. I mean, that's a big leap. That's a big jump. But she's upset. And she's scared, right? We had a fan question from Sally Kay. Was the divorce of Jim's parents a setup for the Michael Helene relationship in season six? Helene is a girl. Helene is a
Pam's mom, everyone. No. This was crafted as a small representation of how our show had dramatic
moments in addition to comedic ones. But because this aired after the Super Bowl, we wanted to stay
away from existing storylines. So the writers had to create kind of like a brand new drama,
but one that wouldn't go on to affect our regular characters too directly. Right. We didn't want
anything in this episode to actually affect the character arcs and relationships that were set in
显然她爸爸现在正在找公寓，离婚正在进行中。正在发生。帕姆变得非常担心。她有一个谈话头，她说，吉姆说了什么能让我爸爸想离开我妈妈？吉姆会在他们婚姻的哪个阶段对她说这些？她正在失控。我觉得她在失控。是的。我的意思是，那是一个很大的飞跃。那是一个很大的跳跃。但她很心烦。而且她很害怕，对吧？我们收到了萨莉·K的粉丝问题。吉姆父母的离婚是为第六季迈克尔和海琳的关系做铺垫吗？海琳是个女孩。海琳是帕姆的妈妈，大家。不。这是为了展示我们的节目除了喜剧时刻外还有戏剧性时刻。但因为这一集是在超级碗之后播出的，我们想远离现有的故事情节。所以编剧们不得不创造一种全新的戏剧，但不会直接影响我们的常规角色。对。我们不想这一集中有任何东西真正影响已经设定的角色弧线和关系。
place. Yes. So that was kind of why this storyline was crafted. And I remember John and I
really fighting for the drama of this, like really saying, no, we want to play this real.
Pam is really upset. This isn't funny upset. Like I remember when I was shooting a three-camera show,
I was supposed to get mad at one of the other characters. And I was supposed to be mad at one of the other characters.
and I was supposed to call him a jerk.
I was supposed to say, you're a jerk.
And the director came over to me and he said, I'm so sorry, this is three camera.
You need to do funny mad, not actual mad.
地方。是的。所以这就是为什么这个故事情节被精心设计的原因。我记得约翰和我真的在为这个戏剧性而斗争，就像真的说，不，我们想真实地演绎这个。帕姆真的很心烦。这不是那种好笑的心烦。就像我记得我拍摄一部三机位节目时，我应该对其中一个角色生气。我应该对其中一个角色生气。我应该叫他混蛋。我应该说，你是个混蛋。导演走过来对我说，我很抱歉，这是三机位。你需要表现出好笑的生气，而不是真正的生气。
You're doing single camera mad.
Yeah.
Funny mad, funny sad.
He said, maybe go up at the end.
You're a jerk.
Yeah.
And I was like, oh, okay.
Or stomp your foot.
你表现的是单机位生气。是的。好笑的生气，好笑的难过。他说，也许最后提高音调。你是个混蛋。是的。我说，哦，好吧。或者跺跺脚。
Yeah, something.
Drop something on your toe and then go, ow, you're a jerk.
Ow.
Oh, see.
This is why you were good at the three camera, Angela.
I couldn't get it.
So anyway, John and I were like, we're going to do real upset.
是的，什么的。踩到脚趾然后说，哎哟，你是个混蛋。哎哟。哦，看。这就是为什么你擅长三机位，安吉拉。我做不到。我做不到。所以无论如何，约翰和我当时想，我们要表现出真正的难过。
And it's going to be okay because all the rest of the episode is going to have the comedy.
You know, the first three camera I did after the office, I played it really real and really quiet.
It was a show called Hot in Cleveland.
I was really excited to do it.
Amazing actresses on that show.
Craig Ferguson was a guest star. He was in there. And the director came over to me and was like, could you talk faster, maybe louder? And could you lower your voice or something? I don't know. Can we get her like some glasses? Anything to make you like a character or something.
Come eat it. Yeah. And Craig Ferguson started cracking up when the director walked away and he was like, maybe get her a top hat, a patch, maybe a parrot for her shoulder.
And Wendy Malick was also in the scene, and she came over and said to me, and she called me
而且没关系，因为这一集的其余部分会有喜剧效果。你知道，我在《办公室》之后做的第一部三机位节目，我表现得非常真实和安静。那是一个叫《魅力克利夫兰》的节目。我非常兴奋能做它。那个节目里有很棒的女演员。克雷格·弗格森是客串明星。他在那里。导演走过来对我说，你能说快点，也许大声点吗？你能降低音调什么的吗？我不知道。我们能给她弄点眼镜吗？任何能让你像个角色什么的。快点。是的。当导演走开时，克雷格·弗格森开始笑起来，他说，也许给她弄个大礼帽，一个眼罩，也许肩膀上放只鹦鹉。温迪·马利克也在那个场景里，她走过来对我说，她叫我
Kid, which I loved.
She goes, kid, you got to sell it to the back row.
This is multi-cam.
I said, got it.
Got it.
Okay.
Yeah.
They did get me glasses, though.
孩子，我很喜欢。她说，孩子，你得把它卖给后排。这是多机位。我说，明白了。明白了。好的。是的。他们确实给我弄了眼镜。
They did?
Were they funny?
Funny.
Betty White did tell me I was funny, though.
That was my takeaway.
Do you have any more stories about legends?
You've got Chloris Leachman.
You've got Betty White.
他们弄了吗？它们好笑吗？好笑。不过贝蒂·怀特确实告诉我我很有趣。那是我的收获。你还有更多关于传奇的故事吗？你有克洛里斯·利奇曼。你有贝蒂·怀特。
We met Carol Burnett once.
Well, I didn't speak, though.
Remember, I was too nervous.
I didn't speak either, but we stood next to her.
I know.
But Kate Plannery talked to her, and we just stood there and smiled.
And then her and Kate got, like, a whole friendship going, I think.
We were so...
我们见过卡罗尔·伯内特一次。好吧，我没说话。记得吗，我太紧张了。我也没说话，但我们站在她旁边。我知道。但凯特·弗兰纳里和她说话了，我们只是站在那里微笑。然后她和凯特似乎建立了一种友谊，我想。我们太……
We just need to go up to Carol Burnett laughing next time.
Oh, no.
I'm going to try that one again.
Oh.
I'm going to get that one out in the future.
Good Lord. You're going to bust it out.
I am.
All right.
我们下次只需要笑着走到卡罗尔·伯内特面前。哦，不。我要再试一次那个。哦。我以后会把那个拿出来的。天哪。你要把它拿出来。我会的。好吧。
Where are we?
Okay.
Jim and Pam, we're playing real moments.
Michael and Dwight are sharing a bottle of many booze.
Very tiny bottle.
Jenna, this is not the first time the tiny bottle of booze has been in an episode.
When was the first time?
All right.
我们在哪？好的。吉姆和帕姆，我们在演真实的时刻。迈克尔和德怀特正在分享一瓶迷你酒。非常小的瓶子。珍娜，这不是迷你酒瓶第一次出现在剧集中。第一次是什么时候？好吧。
In the deleted scenes of the duel, Michael is building up the courage to tell Andy, and they're walking out to the car together.
And Michael hands him a mini bottle of booze out of his pocket in the elevator and goes, drink this.
And then Andy's like, I don't know.
I really like that.
Okay, fine.
And he like, drink's it.
And he's like, ugh.
And he's like, Angela, sleeping with Dwight.
在《决斗》的删减片段中，迈克尔正在鼓起勇气告诉安迪，他们一起走到车外。迈克尔在电梯里从口袋里掏出一瓶迷你酒递给他，说，喝了这个。然后安迪说，我不知道。我真的很喜欢那个。好吧，好吧。他喝了它。他说，呃。他说，安吉拉，和德怀特睡觉。
So I think they had these little mini bottle of booze.
You don't start seeing them in deleted scenes till after they go to Canada.
And I wonder, I wonder if Michael took the mini bar stash.
He 100% did.
Right.
Of course.
That's what I wrote in my head anyway.
Or from the airplane.
所以我认为他们在删减片段中才有这些小迷你酒瓶，直到他们去加拿大之后。我想知道，我想知道迈克尔是不是拿了迷你吧的存货。他百分之百拿了。对。当然。反正我在脑子里就是这么写的。或者从飞机上拿的。
Yes.
First class.
In this scene as they're sharing this mini bottle of booze, we are reminded that Dwight needs to get the signature of everyone in the office.
as an acknowledgement that they have accepted his apology for dismembering the CPR dummy last week.
I mean, how many apology notes is he going to have to have people sign?
I don't know, but he has to get everyone's signature.
He's having a hard time.
是的。头等舱。是的。在这个场景中，当他们分享这瓶迷你酒时，我们被提醒德怀特需要得到办公室里每个人的签名。作为他们接受他为上周拆解CPR假人道歉的确认。我的意思是，他要让人们签多少道歉信？我不知道，但他必须得到每个人的签名。他很难办。
That's the only thing that's stressing him out.
Well, this is when Michael gets his big idea.
They should roast him.
Mm-hmm.
This is great.
He's going to bust into the bullpen.
He's going to announce, we're doing a roast.
I want you to really go at me. Don't hold back.
那是唯一让他感到压力的事情。好吧，这就是迈克尔想到他的大主意的时候。他们应该吐槽他。嗯哼。这太棒了。他要冲进办公区。他要宣布，我们要举办一场吐槽大会。我希望你们真的针对我。不要保留。
Yeah, you can comment on how fit I am or the fact that I'm a womanizer.
He doesn't want to write the material for them, but he wants it to be good.
Everyone is pretty excited. I mean, Kevin is like a giggly. He's so excited.
I liked Oscar's talking head. Say it. He was like, listen, I'm a good person, but I am going to try to make Michael cry.
We had a fan catch from Samantha S and Michelle S.
Two people noticed this catch.
Okay.
If you're following along, starting with Part 2 at 1 minute 15 seconds, Kelly is standing in front of the shelves and her notebook is closed.
是的，你可以评论我有多健康，或者我是个花花公子。他不想为他们写材料，但他希望它很好。每个人都很兴奋。我的意思是，凯文笑嘻嘻的。他太兴奋了。我喜欢奥斯卡的谈话头。说出来。他说，听着，我是个好人，但我会试着让迈克尔哭。我们收到了萨曼莎·S和米歇尔·S的粉丝捕捉。两个人注意到了这个捕捉。好的。如果你跟着看，从第二部分1分15秒开始，凯莉站在架子前，她的笔记本是合上的。
But in the very next shot, it is open and upside down.
Oh, well, we missed that one.
Clearly, she's not really taking an inventory of anything.
Well, I have a question for you.
What is it?
Who is planning this roast?
There's no party planning committee meeting.
But I want you to know, in deleted scenes, I found this gym.
但在下一个镜头里，它是打开的，而且是倒着的。哦，好吧，我们错过了那个。显然，她并没有真正盘点任何东西。好吧，我有个问题要问你。是什么？谁在计划这个吐槽大会？没有派对策划委员会会议。但我希望你知道，在删减片段中，我发现了这个吉姆。
Michael is having a meeting with Daryl in the warehouse.
Oh.
Yeah.
So I'm like, wait, is Daryl in charge of this party?
Because it's in the warehouse.
So Michael is telling Daryl everything he needs.
He says, I would like a stage.
And Daryl points to a few wood pallets.
迈克尔正在仓库里和达里尔开会。哦。是的。所以我心想，等等，达里尔负责这个派对吗？因为它在仓库里。所以迈克尔正在告诉达里尔他需要的一切。他说，我想要一个舞台。达里尔指着几个木托盘。
Okay.
And he's like, well, okay.
And he goes, also, I need a big comfy cheer or maybe a throne.
That made me spit out my coffee.
Then he tells Daryl that he would like all the other roasters to be up on the stage two.
Like, you know, the Comedy Central roast where they have the dais of other roasters up there.
Yeah.
And Daryl's like looking at these tiny wood pallets like, okay.
好的。他说，好吧，好吧。他说，另外，我需要一把舒服的大椅子，或者也许是一个王座。这让我把咖啡喷了出来。然后他告诉达里尔，他希望所有其他的吐槽者也都在舞台上。就像，你知道，喜剧中心的吐槽大会，他们有其他吐槽者的主席台。是的。达里尔看着这些小木托盘，心想，好吧。
Then Daryl's like, who's going to be in the audience?
And Michael's like, we're going to charge $10 a head for the audience.
Who's coming to this?
Yeah, who's coming to this?
Then Michael's like, oh, also we need alcohol.
Okay, you need lots of alcohol.
and I'm going to need something to spit in for my spit takes.
Oh, he's planning out that this is going to be so funny.
然后达里尔说，谁会在观众席上？迈克尔说，我们要向观众收取每人10美元。谁会来参加这个？是的，谁会来参加这个？然后迈克尔说，哦，还有，我们需要酒精。好的，你需要大量的酒精。我还需要一些东西来吐我的喷水镜头。哦，他正在计划这将是多么有趣。
He's going to need to spit out his drink.
And Daryl's like, you're not spitting in the warehouse.
Then Dwight rushes in and he's got this 8 by 10 photo of Michael.
And Michael's like, no, no, no, no, no.
I want this photo huge.
It's got to cover like the whole back wall.
Okay?
Yeah.
他需要吐出他的饮料。达里尔说，你不能在仓库里吐。然后德怀特冲了进来，他拿着这张迈克尔的8x10照片。迈克尔说，不，不，不，不，不。我要这张照片巨大。它必须覆盖整个后墙。好的？是的。
And then he says, I also want a drum and symbol so I can do the ba-dum bumps.
This is amazing because all of these things are going to appear in the warehouse.
house. Yes. So I'm thinking Daryl and Dwight planned this. They were the PPC for this event.
I don't want to give too much of a spoiler, but next week, we're going to find out what happened to
the PPC and why there is no one in charge of party planning right now. Oh, yeah. So this was like
foreshadowing. A little bit. Well, I guess they set everything up and Dwight has a great idea. It's actually a
great idea. It's brilliant. He tells everyone as they're entering that they have to sign in for
The roast. But what they're really signing is his apology acknowledgement sheet. Yes. But who catches it?
然后他说，我还想要一个鼓和镲，这样我就可以做“ba-dum bumps”。这太神奇了，因为所有这些东西都会出现在仓库里。是的。所以我认为达里尔和德怀特计划了这个。他们是这次活动的PPC。我不想剧透太多，但下周，我们将找出PPC发生了什么，以及为什么现在没有人负责派对策划。哦，是的。所以这就像是伏笔。一点点。好吧，我想他们设置好了一切，德怀特有一个好主意。这实际上是一个好主意。这很天才。他告诉每个人当他们进入时，他们必须签到参加吐槽大会。但他们真正签署的是他的道歉确认表。是的。但谁抓住了它？
Phyllis. So good. She's so good. She is just busting his butt through this whole episode.
She will not sign. She's not going to sign. She's the holdout. Yeah. Everyone takes their seats.
Michael sits on his throne. And now the roast is going to begin. Yeah. Should we take a break?
I think we take a break and we come back with the roasting.
Okay, folks, the roast is on.
Michael welcomes all these jerks.
Yeah.
Who's first up?
菲利斯。太棒了。她太棒了。她在这一整集中都在折磨他。她不会签名的。她不会签名的。她是那个坚持不签的人。是的。每个人都坐下了。迈克尔坐在他的王座上。现在吐槽大会要开始了。是的。我们休息一下吗？我想我们休息一下，回来进行吐槽。好的，伙计们，吐槽大会开始了。迈克尔欢迎所有这些混蛋。是的。谁是第一个？
Who can't wait to get up there and roast Michael Scott?
He can barely finish his sentence and she's grabbing the microphone.
It's Angela Martin.
That's right.
Jenna, I noticed something in rewatching this multiple times like we do each week.
Is Angela Martin ripping off Jeff Foxworthy bits?
Yes, you know Angela Martin is a Jeff Foxworthy fan.
She's, I mean, listen, listen to Jeff and then listen to Angela.
谁迫不及待地想上去吐槽迈克尔·斯科特？他几乎还没说完话，她就抢过了麦克风。是安吉拉·马丁。没错。珍娜，我在像我们每周那样多次重看这一集时注意到了一些事情。安吉拉·马丁是在抄袭杰夫·福克斯沃西的段子吗？是的，你知道安吉拉·马丁是杰夫·福克斯沃西的粉丝。她是，我的意思是，听，听杰夫的，然后听安吉拉的。
If you've ever cut your grass and found a car, you might be a red neck.
And now, Angela.
If you ever put sunblock on a window, you might be Michael Scott.
If you ever called the fire department because your head was stuck in your chair, you might be.
Michael Scott.
Yes.
She clearly.
is doing Jeff spit. Yes, 100%. When I rewatch that, I was like, oh my gosh, that had to be the writer's
如果你曾经割草时发现了一辆车，你可能就是个乡巴佬。现在，安吉拉。如果你曾经在窗户上涂防晒霜，你可能就是迈克尔·斯科特。如果你曾经因为头卡在椅子里而打电话给消防局，你可能就是。迈克尔·斯科特。是的。她显然。是在用杰夫的段子。是的，100%。当我重看那个时，我想，哦，天哪，那一定是编剧的
inspiration for Angela's comedic style. I was very impressed with how prepared Angela was.
Prepared and her mic work. Like she took the mic off, waved it to the crowd for everyone to say Michael
Scott. She was into it. Next up is Kelly. And she does a list of who and what she would rather kiss
than Michael Scott. All right. I got to jump in and just tell you guys there are
so much extra stuff in the deleted scenes for the roast. We also find out Kelly has a second bit
where she says she knows that Michael dyes his hair. Oh, yeah. That one day it was raining and his
hair dye dripped onto her arm and she color matched it and Michael uses Clarell Natural Instincts
Midnight Black. She does this whole other bit. And then I think Meredith is the most depressing.
灵感来源，安吉拉的喜剧风格。我对安吉拉的准备工作印象深刻。准备好了，还有她的麦克风工作。就像她把麦克风拿下来，向人群挥手让每个人说迈克尔·斯科特。她很投入。接下来是凯莉。她列出了她宁愿亲吻谁和什么，而不是迈克尔·斯科特。好吧，我得插一句，告诉你们，吐槽大会的删减片段里有太多额外的东西。我们还发现凯莉有第二个段子，她说她知道迈克尔染发。哦，是的。有一天天下雨，他的染发剂滴到了她的手臂上，她进行了颜色匹配，迈克尔用的是Clarell Natural Instincts午夜黑。她做了这整个其他的段子。然后我觉得梅雷迪思是最令人沮丧的。
She says, Michael, you are the reason I drink. You're the reason I drink. You're the reason I
live to forget.
Yeah.
Oof.
Oscar roasts Michael in Spanish.
And he speaks very quickly.
He has a lot to say.
A lot to say.
她说，迈克尔，你是我喝酒的原因。你是我喝酒的原因。你是我活着为了忘记的原因。是的。呜。奥斯卡用西班牙语吐槽迈克尔。他说话非常快。他有很多话要说。有很多话要说。
Very passionate.
There's so much more Oscar in the deleted scenes.
First of all, he does multiple jokes in English before he gets to his Spanish roast.
And I think we need to hear him.
The only man in the state of Pennsylvania who is less likely to get legally married than me is Michael Scott.
Michael Scott is so good.
dumb. He thinks balancing a checkbook is putting a checkbook on his nose and shouting,
look at me! Look at me!
非常热情。删减片段里有更多的奥斯卡。首先，他在进行西班牙语吐槽之前，用英语讲了多个笑话。我觉得我们需要听听。宾夕法尼亚州唯一一个比我更不可能合法结婚的男人就是迈克尔·斯科特。迈克尔·斯科特太笨了。他认为平衡支票簿就是把支票簿放在鼻子上大喊，看着我！看着我！
Michael is so bad with money, he invested in Enron. Last week.
That was privileged.
Michael is the biggest idiot I know.
And finally, sometimes I lay awake at night, I'm sure all of you do too, and wonder,
what the hell did I do to deserve a boss like this?
I mean...
Oh, my gosh.
He just calls him an idiot.
迈克尔对金钱太糟糕了，他投资了安然。上周。那是特权。迈克尔是我认识的最白痴的人。最后，有时我晚上躺在床上，我相信你们所有人也是，想，我到底做了什么才配得上这样一个老板？我的意思是……哦，天哪。他直接叫他白痴。
Oh, my gosh.
Michael is kind of realizing that maybe this wasn't as fun as he thought it would be, but things are in motion now.
Yeah.
And everyone can't wait to get up on stage.
Toby tries to have a turn, but Michael shoots him down.
Yeah, he says only friends, friends only.
And then there is a deleted scene, Jenna, where Oscar brings a cell phone up on stage because
Jan, who isn't there, has decided to call in so she can roast Michael.
哦，天哪。迈克尔有点意识到这可能不像他想的那么有趣，但事情现在已经开始了。是的。每个人都迫不及待地想上台。托比试图轮到他，但迈克尔拒绝了他。是的，他说只有朋友，只有朋友。然后有一个删减片段，珍娜，奥斯卡把手机带上了舞台，因为不在那里的简决定打电话进来，这样她就可以吐槽迈克尔。
Amazing.
All right, we got to hear it.
Well, Michael, you ruined my life.
Okay?
Everything you touch turns to crap.
Okay.
You have no sense of how to please any woman.
I can't believe that once you wrote a phone message on my diploma and you used my daughter's
太棒了。好吧，我们得听听。好吧，迈克尔，你毁了我的生活。好的？你碰过的所有东西都变成了垃圾。好的。你根本不知道怎么取悦任何女人。我不敢相信你曾经在我的毕业证书上写过电话留言，而且你用我女儿的
christening gown as a bib when you eat ribs.
I mean, you're just completely an ass, Michael.
You're an ass.
Okay, I have to say, clearly the writers had a lot of fun writing this roast because in addition to all these deleted scenes, remember last week when I said our candy bag for this episode was 207 pages?
Are all jokes? Were they all roasting jokes?
They are almost all alternate roast jokes.
Well, I do.
Pages and pages and pages.
洗礼袍当围兜吃排骨。我的意思是，你完全是个混蛋，迈克尔。你是个混蛋。好的，我必须说，显然编剧们在写这个吐槽大会时玩得很开心，因为除了所有这些删减片段，还记得上周我说我们这一集的糖果袋有207页吗？全是笑话吗？它们都是吐槽笑话吗？它们几乎全是备选的吐槽笑话。好吧，我确实。页复一页。
Oh, my gosh. I do remember, Jenna, that people got up multiple times.
Oh, yeah. They just kept handing us stuff to go say. In the candy bag, they had all these
alts for Jan when she called in. So in addition to this deleted one, this one really stuck out
to me. She says, it only took one night of misguided, drunken passion with Michael to ruin my
entire life. I would have been better off if he'd just given me syphilis. Oh, my gosh.
Well, now Jim is going to get up. And he's.
He's going, I guess, list all of the sayings that Michael has butchered.
Spider-face.
哦，天哪。我确实记得，珍娜，人们多次上台。哦，是的。他们只是不断地递给我们东西去说。在糖果袋里，他们有简打电话进来的所有备选内容。所以除了这个删减的，这个真的让我印象深刻。她说，只需要一个晚上与迈克尔误入歧途的醉酒激情就毁了我的一生。如果他只是给了我梅毒，我会更好。哦，天哪。好吧，现在吉姆要上台了。他。他要，我想，列出迈克尔糟蹋的所有谚语。蜘蛛脸。
Oh, my gosh.
Dwight is feeling bad for Michael.
So he hops up on stage to defend him, right?
Yeah.
And Michael's like, idiot, you're doing it wrong.
You're doing it wrong.
And then Dwight snaps and is like, what, you're calling me an idiot?
Like, he's up there trying to defend him.
哦，天哪。德怀特为迈克尔感到难过。所以他跳上舞台为他辩护，对吧？是的。迈克尔就像，白痴，你做错了。你做错了。然后德怀特爆发了，就像，什么，你叫我白痴？就像，他在上面试图为他辩护。
He's like, you're just a small, pathetic little man.
You have no friends, no feelings.
no family and no land.
And he walks off stage and everyone cheers.
Well, now it's Pam's turn.
I remember so clearly shooting this.
I remember because after roasting him about falling for internet scams and being lazy at work,
I had to say that Michael's penis is small.
他说，你只是一个渺小、可怜的小男人。你没有朋友，没有感情。没有家人，没有土地。他走下舞台，每个人都在欢呼。好吧，现在轮到帕姆了。我清楚地记得拍摄这个场景。我记得因为在吐槽他相信互联网骗局和工作懒惰之后，我不得不说迈克尔的阴茎很小。
I mean, this is the ultimate nail in the coffin of the roast.
For Michael in particular.
I mean, Michael who's like, thinks he's like the womanizer.
Because remember, in an earlier episode, Pam knocked on the door and Michael said, come in,
and he did not have his clothes on.
And Pam was like, why did you say come in?
He was changing for Fun Run.
Exactly.
我的意思是，这是吐槽大会的终极棺材钉。特别是对迈克尔来说。我的意思是，迈克尔，他认为自己是花花公子。因为记得吗，在之前的一集中，帕姆敲门，迈克尔说，进来，他没穿衣服。帕姆说，你为什么要说进来？他正在换衣服准备参加趣味跑。完全正确。
So Pam is going to call that back, and she's going to make a joke at his expense.
We did this a few ways, that we started by having me just say it on the stage.
But then they thought, this is kind of a low blow, right?
Yeah, and it's bold for Pam.
It is.
So they were like, let's try this one on the move.
Yeah, like a throwaway.
Exactly.
所以帕姆打算回击，她要拿他开涮。我们试了几种方式，起初是让我直接在台上说。但后来他们觉得，这有点下作，对吧？是的，这对帕姆来说很大胆。确实。所以他们说，试着边走边说吧。对，就像随口一说。没错。
And so that's what ended up making it into the episode.
And then we have an old tech alert that helps you really just punch them one more time.
Oh, yeah.
Everyone's like, how small is it?
And then Pam says, if it were an iPod, it'd be a shuffle.
Do some people even know that joke?
Do they even get that joke?
Do people still have iPods?
最后这一版被剪进了剧集里。然后我们有个老科技梗，能让你真的再补上一刀。哦，对。大家都问，它有多小？然后帕姆说，如果是iPod的话，那肯定是Shuffle。有些人甚至知道这个梗吗？他们能听懂吗？现在还有人用iPod吗？
It was a big deal.
we were so excited to have our iPods with all of our music on it.
Just music.
Only music guys.
And they came in different sizes and shuffle was the smallest.
Yeah.
And you could get a tiny one and like clip it on your like arm band and go running.
I never did that because I don't run.
那可是个大事件。我们当时特别兴奋，能拥有装满我们所有音乐的iPod。只有音乐。伙计们，只有音乐。它们有不同尺寸，Shuffle是最小的。对，你可以买个超小的，夹在臂带上跑步。我从没那样做过，因为我不跑步。
But you could have.
You could have.
It looked cool.
Yeah.
With your headphones that had a cord that had to go to it.
So you couldn't pump your arms too hard.
No.
但你可以那样做。你可以的。看起来很酷。对，还有那根必须连着的耳机线。所以你不能太用力摆动双臂。不。不。
Oh, how many times did I just yank that cord out of my iPod?
I know.
Because I was just your, not exercising.
I'm so sorry, please don't get the wrong idea.
I was gesturing wildly.
Well, now Daryl's going to come up, and this one was really cringy.
Daryl says, Michael, you always say we're family, right?
Yep.
哦，我多少次不小心把那根线从iPod上扯下来过？我知道。因为我只是在……不是在锻炼。抱歉，请别误会。我只是在夸张地做手势。好了，现在达里尔要上场了，这一段真的很尴尬。达里尔说，迈克尔，你总是说我们是一家人，对吧？没错。
So if your family, you know everyone's names.
What's that guy's name?
And he points to a warehouse employee.
And Michael clearly doesn't know his name.
And it's so awkward.
His name is Michael.
And not only is his name Michael, but Michael gave him a car ride home, and they were in traffic for like an hour together.
Awkward.
所以如果是一家人，你应该知道每个人的名字。那个人叫什么名字？他指着一个仓库员工。迈克尔显然不知道他的名字。这太尴尬了。他叫迈克尔。而且不仅他叫迈克尔，迈克尔还曾载过他回家，他们一起在交通堵塞中待了一个小时。尴尬。
But really what rounds it all out is everyone singing what I hate about you.
Yeah.
Andy gets up.
Yeah, he's written the song.
We have it.
We got to hear it.
You're the loosiest, jerkiest, and you're dumber than apple sauce.
We're stuck listening to you all day.
但真正让这一切圆满的是大家一起唱《我讨厌你》。对。安迪站起来了。对，他写了这首歌。我们有录音。我们得听听。你是最松散、最混蛋的，你比苹果酱还蠢。我们整天被困着听你说话。
Stanley tried to die just to get away when it's true.
That's what I hate about.
you. That was so amazing. It was so amazing on the day. We were all singing. I want you guys to know,
people have asked, you know, Ed did not write those lyrics. That was written by our writers.
Ed figured out how to play the song on the guitar, but that was scripted. It was so good.
So good. But you know what? Our writers could throw Ed anything. And I felt like he just was like,
Done. I mean, that's a good thing to have. It is. Secret weapon.
Well, guys, Michael isn't happy. It looks like he might cry. And then the next day,
斯坦利为了逃离甚至想死，这是真的。这就是我讨厌你的原因。那太棒了。那天拍的时候太棒了。我们都在唱。我想让你们知道，有人问过，埃德并没有写那些歌词。那是我们的编剧写的。埃德弄清楚了怎么用吉他弹这首歌，但那是写在剧本里的。太棒了。太棒了。但你知道吗？我们的编剧可以给埃德任何东西。我觉得他就像是，搞定。我是说，这是一种很好的能力。确实。秘密武器。好了，伙计们，迈克尔不高兴了。看起来他快哭了。然后第二天，
the phone rings and Pam says Michael's not in the office. Michael didn't come to work.
No. He's so depressed. Dwight says it's very unusual for Michael not to show up. He is either depressed or maybe he's been impaled by an icicle.
He does have a terrible habit of standing underneath them, staring up at them, despite Dwight's many warnings.
Many warnings. The gang is in the break room, you know, sort of saying, is he okay? What should we do?
Yeah. And Creed has one of those lines, Jenna, that made John break. Yeah. It's a classic Creed line. Phyllis says, I hope he's okay. I feel bad. Creed says, give it up. He's dead. Jim says, he just sent a text. Creed goes, what's a text? What's a text?
What's a text?
Like, sent everyone into laughing fits.
That aspect of Creed's character was John's kryptonite.
电话响了，帕姆说迈克尔不在办公室。迈克尔没来上班。不。他太沮丧了。德怀特说迈克尔不出现很不寻常。他要么是抑郁了，要么可能是被冰柱刺穿了。他确实有个坏习惯，总是站在冰柱下面盯着它们看，尽管德怀特警告过他很多次。很多次。大家都在休息室，你知道，都在说，他没事吧？我们该怎么办？对。克里德说了句台词，珍娜，让约翰笑场了。对，这是克里德的经典台词。菲利斯说，我希望他没事。我感觉很不好。克里德说，放弃吧。他死了。吉姆说，他刚发了条短信。克里德说，什么是短信？什么是短信？什么是短信？让所有人都笑得停不下来。克里德角色的这一面是约翰的软肋。
Yes.
Yeah.
The you're not real.
You're not real.
What's a text?
Yeah.
Like, he loved that stuff.
Well, we do eventually find Michael.
是的。对，那个“你不是真的。你不是真的。什么是短信？”对。他很喜欢那种东西。好吧，我们最终找到了迈克尔。
He is sitting alone at a playground.
And a black turtleneck with a black coat.
He looks the sleekest he's ever looked.
I'm like, what is this casual outfit?
I know.
And he has, like, nice jeans on.
with like appropriate sort of black dress shoes kind of.
He's feeding full slices of bread to invisible birds.
他独自坐在操场上。穿着黑色高领毛衣和黑色外套。他看起来是他有史以来最时髦的样子。我在想，这是什么休闲装扮？我知道。他穿着不错的牛仔裤，配着合适的黑色正装鞋。他正在给看不见的鸟喂整片的面包。
Yeah.
I'll have you know this location alert.
This was North Hollywood Community Center Park,
where we shot this little bit of Steve and his turtleneck.
There's lots more in the deleted scenes.
Oh dear.
Him talking to little kids, him trying to shoot baskets.
Like, yeah.
对。我得告诉你们这个外景地。这是北好莱坞社区中心公园，我们在这里拍摄了史蒂夫和他的高领毛衣的那一小段。删减片段里还有很多。哦天哪。他跟小孩子说话，他尝试投篮。就像，对。
Michael explains in a talking head that, you know,
sometimes he has to get away.
He needs to get perspective.
and we learn like he is not okay.
Right.
But him imagining a spaceman on a star very far away.
That might help him.
迈克尔在采访中解释说，你知道，有时他必须离开。他需要换个角度看问题。我们了解到他状态不好。对。但他想象着一个远方星星上的宇航员。那可能会帮到他。那可能会帮到他。
Get that perspective.
Yeah.
Back in the office, Dwight is still trying to get Phyllis's signature on this form.
She's the only one.
She's the only one that hasn't signed.
So guess what?
Delivery.
There's a delivery man.
换个角度。对。回到办公室，德怀特还在试图让菲利斯在这张表格上签字。她是唯一一个。她是唯一一个还没签字的人。所以猜猜怎么着？快递。有个快递员。
Yeah.
Who has come in in a very, I would say, noticeably generic uniform.
Mm-hmm.
There's a package for Phyllis.
For Phyllis, but she has to sign for it.
Yeah.
I loved this gag.
She signs the clipboard, and as soon as she signs, the clipboard like disappears from the man's hands.
对。他穿着一件非常，我会说，明显很普通的制服进来了。嗯哼。有个给菲利斯的包裹。给菲利斯的，但她必须签收。对。我喜欢这个梗。她签了写字板，就在她签完的一瞬间，写字板从那人手里消失了。
It's got like one of those chains and it's being drug away.
The pin has a chain to the clipboard.
And it's Dwight over in the hallway.
He got his signature.
He did.
Well, this was a fun cameo played by our very own producer, James Carey.
Yes, James Carey, who's been helping us out on the podcast.
Yeah.
它连着一根链子，被拖走了。笔用链子连在写字板上。是走廊那边的德怀特。他拿到了签名。他拿到了。好吧，这是一个由我们自己的制片人詹姆斯·凯里客串的有趣片段。是的，詹姆斯·凯里，他一直在播客上帮我们。对。
Yeah. This is him. If you wondered what he looked like, there he is. There he is. James was on the show the whole time. Yeah, he was with us from the very beginning. From the very beginning. So it was really fun to have him on stage with us filming. And we reached out to him and asked him about this moment. James said that he never asked to be an actor on the show. And one day he just got this random phone call from Ben, who worked in Allison Jones's office. Ben was Allison's casting associate. And,
He told him, we have a role in stress relief.
There's one line.
We'd like you to play it.
And James was like, yes, of course I said yes.
And this was just, you know, this was just a cool thing that Greg and Allison would do from time to time.
They would feature longtime crew members in the show.
Well, we would always get really excited.
对。这就是他。如果你好奇他长什么样，那就是他。就是他。詹姆斯一直都在剧组里。对，他从一开始就和我们在一起。从一开始。所以能让他和我们一起在台上拍摄真的很有趣。我们联系了他，问他关于这一刻的事。詹姆斯说他从未要求在剧中当演员。有一天他突然接到了本的电话，本在艾莉森·琼斯的办公室工作。本是艾莉森的选角助理。而且，他告诉他，我们在《压力缓解》里有个角色。只有一句台词。我们想让你演。詹姆斯说，是的，我当然说了愿意。这只是，你知道，这是格雷格和艾莉森偶尔会做的一件很酷的事。他们会让长期的剧组成员在剧中露脸。好吧，我们总是会感到非常兴奋。
And James told us that for him, the day on set was really fun, exciting.
I mean, he'd worked for a long time.
the entertainment industry. But he said when you're in front of the camera and other people are
depending on you to hit your mark and deliver your dialogue, all of a sudden, he got really nervous.
And he said he was expecting a little more directing because he's not an actor at all.
But they didn't really give him much. They're just like, go there. Say your line. But he did say,
after one or two takes, Jeff Blitz suggested to him, maybe look like you're up to something,
you know, give it a little something. And he's like, I think that's the take.
詹姆斯告诉我们，对他来说，在片场的那天真的很有趣，很令人兴奋。我是说，他在娱乐行业工作了很长时间。但他说当你站在摄像机前，别人都指望你站好位置并说出台词时，突然间，他变得非常紧张。他说他期待更多的指导，因为他根本不是演员。但他们并没有给他太多指导。他们只是说，去那儿。说你的台词。但他确实说，拍了一两次之后，杰夫·布里茨建议他，也许表现得像你在密谋什么，你知道，加点戏。他说，我觉得那条就是最后用的。
used. But his whole family saw it because it was on after the Super Bowl. Yes. But James said when they
first said, we've got a role for you. It's one line as a delivery man. He didn't realize it was
for the stress relief episode. Yeah. So when he said yes, he just wasn't putting it together that he
was saying yes to the Super Bowl episode. He said his dad was particularly excited. And when he told
his brother and sister at first, he said he thinks they didn't believe him. They thought he was
kidding? Yeah, yeah. He said they were like, yeah, sure, you're going to be on. Yeah, whatever.
And then there he was. He was on it. Well, the episode is wrapping up, and so is the movie,
Mrs. Albert Hannity. And he's moved to tears. He's watching Jack Black and Cloris Leachman
但他的全家人都看到了，因为它是在超级碗之后播出的。是的。但詹姆斯说当他们第一次说，我们有个角色给你。是快递员的一句台词。他没意识到那是《压力缓解》那一集。对。所以当他答应时，他没把这和超级碗剧集联系起来。他说他爸爸特别兴奋。当他第一次告诉他兄弟姐妹时，他说他觉得他们不相信他。他们以为他在开玩笑？对，对。他说他们就像，是啊，当然，你要上电视了。是啊，随便吧。然后他就真的出现在上面了。好吧，这一集快结束了，电影《阿尔伯特·汉尼蒂夫人》也快结束了。他热泪盈眶。他看着杰克·布莱克和克洛里斯·利奇曼
break up. Yeah, she's very slowly moving up the staircase in her special motorized chair.
And he's crying saying, hit reverse. So I shared last week that we shot this on location at a house
in West Los Angeles, Randy told me the house already had this chairlift.
We did not install it.
I would think that they scouted a house with a chairlift.
He also said that because they wanted this mini film to really look like a real movie,
we shot the Mrs. Hannaday sequence on film.
Dang!
分手。对，她正非常缓慢地坐着特制的电动椅上楼梯。他哭着说，倒带。所以我上周分享过，我们是在西洛杉矶的一所房子里实地拍摄的，兰迪告诉我那房子本来就有这个升降椅。我们没有安装它。我想他们是专门找了一所有升降椅的房子。他还说，因为他们想让这部微电影看起来像真正的电影，我们用胶片拍摄了汉尼蒂夫人的片段。天哪！
It was our first time shooting something for our show on film.
We normally used the digital cameras.
We even had a steady cam film camera.
And since they only had one day to shoot all these scenes, Jeff Blitz and Randall Einhorn did a full blocking rehearsal with stand-ins where they planned out every single shot.
They created official storyboards just like you do on a film.
And Randy even sent us pictures.
Yeah.
And they exactly match the mini movie.
这是我们第一次用胶片拍摄剧集内容。我们通常用数字摄像机。我们甚至有一台斯坦尼康胶片摄像机。由于他们只有一天时间拍摄所有这些场景，杰夫·布里茨和兰德尔·艾因霍恩用替身进行了完整的走位排练，规划了每一个镜头。他们制作了正式的分镜脚本，就像拍电影一样。兰迪甚至给我们发了照片。对。它们和微电影完全吻合。
There's a woman who's standing in for.
Chloris Leachman, kind of slowly moving up the staircase. And that is how they were able to get
this elaborate shoot done on film, which normally takes a lot longer than shooting on digital.
They could do it in one day. Yes. So Randy sent us pictures of how they staged it. And it was so
fun to see them because Anna, who was in charge of locations, played Jack Black. And then Jasmine,
who was our second AD, plays Chloris Lechman. So we'll have to put one of those pictures
in our stories. It was fun to see their faces.
In addition to wrapping up the movie storyline, we're going to find out what exactly Jim said to Pam's dad.
有个女人替克洛里斯·利奇曼站位，缓慢地移动上楼梯。这就是他们能用胶片完成这种复杂拍摄的原因，这通常比数字拍摄花的时间长得多。他们一天就完成了。是的。所以兰迪给我们发了他们如何布置的照片。看到这些照片太有趣了，因为负责外景的安娜扮演了杰克·布莱克。然后我们的第二副导演贾斯敏扮演了克洛里斯·利奇曼。我们得把其中一张照片发到我们的故事里。看到他们的脸很有趣。除了结束电影剧情，我们还要找出吉姆到底对帕姆的爸爸说了什么。
Yeah, Pam's dad comes to the office and they have this whole conversation in the parking lot.
Now, we can't hear it.
We see it, but we don't know what they're saying.
We had a fan question from Stephanie P.
What did Pam say to her dad in the parking lot?
There was never any dialogue for this in the script.
This was always a silent spy shop.
In fact, here's what it said.
对，帕姆的爸爸来到办公室，他们在停车场进行了全程对话。现在，我们听不到。我们看到了，但不知道他们在说什么。我们有个来自斯蒂芬妮·P的粉丝提问。帕姆在停车场对她爸爸说了什么？剧本里从来没有这段对话。这一直是一个无声的偷拍镜头。事实上，剧本上是这样写的。
It said, Jim's POV, Pam is talking with her father.
The conversation goes back and forth.
Pam looks angry.
The dad says something.
She looks up at Jim with tears in her eyes.
The dad leaves, and Pam walks back inside.
So you guys just had to fill in the blanks there.
We did.
上面写着，吉姆的视角，帕姆正在和她父亲交谈。对话来回进行。帕姆看起来很生气。爸爸说了些什么。她眼里含着泪水抬头看着吉姆。爸爸离开了，帕姆走回室内。所以你们只需要填补空白。我们确实填补了。
Now, Pam's dad was played by Rick Overton, and he will be back again in Niagara.
And Rick is actually a really funny guy.
He's like an improvisation comedy veteran.
He's also a writer.
He won an Emmy for writing an episode of Dennis Miller Live.
So it's funny to me how we would cast people with great pedigree to stand and do a silent POV shot in the parking lot.
Yeah.
But that was because this is a big role, Pam's dad.
现在，帕姆的爸爸由里克·奥弗顿饰演，他还会回到《尼亚加拉》那一集。里克其实是个非常有趣的人。他是个即兴喜剧老手。他也是个编剧。他曾因编写《丹尼斯·米勒直播》的一集而获得艾美奖。所以我觉得很有趣，我们竟然会请有这种背景的人来停车场拍一个无声的视角镜头。对。但那是因为这是一个大角色，帕姆的爸爸。
If we bring him back, we need to make sure this person has the chops to go the distance.
Yeah.
And Rick was great.
And we just improvised dialogue.
We just improvised what he might be saying to her that would cause her to be hurt.
It was mostly a spin on like, I'm sorry, but I need to leave your mother.
You know, he knew that scripted line that Pam says later.
And he would say that to me and I would look up at the window and all that kind of stuff.
如果我们让他回来，我们需要确保这个人有能力胜任。对。里克很棒。我们只是即兴发挥了对话。我们即兴发挥了他可能对她说的话，导致她受伤。这主要是像，“我很抱歉，但我得离开你母亲。”你知道，他知道帕姆后来说的那些台词。他会对我说那些话，我会抬头看着窗户，诸如此类。
So yeah.
But he was great.
And by the way, he reached out to us because he knew we were coming up on this episode.
episode, and he said, if you would not mind, would you tell people that I have a new,
improvised stand-up special called Rick Overton's set list, and you can find it through
comedy dynamics. Oh, nice. And we can put a link in the show notes for anyone who wants to check it out.
That's great. Well, this all leads us into this Pam talking head that gets quoted back to me
all the time. It's a very sweet talking head. It is. Pam says, when you're young, you assume
所以是的。但他很棒。顺便说一下，他联系了我们，因为他知道我们要讲到这一集了，他说，如果你不介意的话，能不能告诉大家我有一个新的即兴单口喜剧特辑叫《里克·奥弗顿的歌单》，你可以通过喜剧动力找到它。哦，不错。我们可以在节目笔记里放个链接，给想看的人。太棒了。好吧，这一切引出了帕姆的采访，这段话经常被引用。这是一个非常甜蜜的采访。确实。帕姆说，当你年轻时，你以为
your parents are soulmates. Her kids are going to be right about that.
Yeah. Andy overhears it, throws papers in the air because he's like, his whole running bit is that Pam and Jim are sort of relationship geniuses and that they can see all of this stuff happening in a movie that he can't see, this deep relationship like storyline that he just can't see. Because it's not there, Andy.
No. He says he would never be insightful enough to be a movie critic, but he could maybe be a food or art critic.
Mm-hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Here comes Michael in his black turtleneck and his black coat. I'm still, like, obsessed with this outfit. He said he spent the afternoon in the park trying to feed pigeons, but I guess they'd all flown west for the winter. Yeah. And he just had some thoughts he wanted to share with everyone. Pam says what? Mm-hmm. And he said, I wrote him down, so I wouldn't forget. Oh, boy. Here it comes. This is the boom roasted's.
It is. Boom. Roasted. So you know, I told you that Hallstead Sullivan came up with the idea for the roast storyline. Yeah. I had to know who came up with boom, roasted. Who did? All right. I got a hot tip that it might be Justin Spitzer or Gene Stubnitsky. Okay. I reached out to them. And? Nope. Nope. They thought maybe it was Charlie Grandi. Oh, was it? I don't have Charlie's info. Oh.
So I reached out to Jen Salada.
Plot thickens.
I said, Jen, do you know if Charlie Grandy wrote Boom Roasted?
你的父母是灵魂伴侣。她的孩子们会是对的。对。安迪听到了，把纸扔向空中，因为他的整个梗就是帕姆和吉姆是某种关系天才，他们能看到电影里发生的所有事情，而他看不到，这种深刻的关系剧情他就是看不见。因为那根本不存在，安迪。不。他说他永远不会有足够的洞察力去当影评人，但他或许可以当个美食或艺术评论家。嗯哼。嗯。嗯。迈克尔穿着他的黑色高领毛衣和黑色外套来了。我仍然对这身装扮着迷。他说他在公园里花了一下午试图喂鸽子，但我猜它们冬天都飞往西方了。对。他只是有些想法想和大家分享。帕姆说，什么？嗯哼。他说，我把它们写下来了，这样我就不会忘。哦，天哪。来了。这就是“Boom Roasted”的时刻。确实。Boom。Roasted。所以你知道，我告诉过你霍尔斯特德·沙利文想出了吐槽剧情的点子。对。我得知道是谁想出了“Boom Roasted”。是谁？好吧。我有个可靠消息，可能是贾斯汀·斯皮策或吉恩·斯图尼茨基。好的。我联系了他们。然后呢？没有。没有。他们觉得可能是查理·格兰迪。哦，是他吗？我没有查理的联系方式。哦。所以我联系了珍·萨拉达。情节变得复杂了。我说，珍，你知道是不是查理·格兰迪写的“Boom Roasted”吗？
Yeah.
These are the emails I exchanged with people now.
I know.
Oh, I know.
Jen said, I think so, but let me text him.
And then I just love Jen Salada so much.
I know.
She writes me back, Boom Roasted was Charlie!
对。这些就是我现在和人们交换的邮件。我知道。哦，我知道。珍说，我想是，但我发短信问问他。我太喜欢珍·萨拉达了。我知道。她回信说，Boom Roasted是查理写的！
Three exclamation points.
We did it.
So I wrote Justin and I said, Justin, it was Charlie Brandy.
And he said, great, I would like some credit on the podcast.
for sending you down the right road.
I said you will get it.
Thank you, Justin.
Thank you all of you guys.
三个感叹号。我们做到了。所以我写信给贾斯汀说，贾斯汀，是查理·格兰迪写的。他说，太好了，我想在播客上获得一些功劳，因为我指引你走上了正确的道路。我说你会得到的。谢谢你，贾斯汀。谢谢你们所有人。
I know, I know.
I had to know.
Boom roasted.
Who did Boomer roasted?
Charlie Grandy.
Well, I think we need to hear these.
I'm going to read them to you.
Michael says,
我知道，我知道。我必须知道。Boom roasted。谁写的Boom roasted？查理·格兰迪。好吧，我觉得我们得听听这些。我要读给你们听。迈克尔说，
Jim, you're 611 and you weigh 90 pounds.
Gumby has a better body than you.
Boom, roasted.
Dwight, you're a kiss ass.
Pam, you failed art school.
Boom. Roasted. Meredith, you've slept with so many guys. You've started to look like one.
Boom. Roasted. Kevin, I can't decide between a fat joke and a dumb joke.
吉姆，你身高6英尺11英寸，体重90磅。甘比的身材都比你好。Boom，roasted。德怀特，你是个马屁精。Boom，roasted。帕姆，你没能从艺术学校毕业。Boom。Roasted。梅雷迪斯，你和太多男人睡过了。你开始看起来像个男人了。Boom。Roasted。凯文，我无法在胖子笑话和傻子笑话之间做出选择。
Boom. Roasted. Creed, your teeth called. Your breast stinks.
Boom. Roasted. Angela. Where's Angela? Oh, there you are. I didn't see you there behind that grain of rice.
Boom. Roasted. Stanley, you crush your wife during sex and your heart sucks.
Boom. Roasted.
Oscar, you are.
Gay. Boom, roasted. Andy Cornell called. They think you suck and you're gayer than Oscar. Boom, roasted. Well, now Stanley is cackling.
Hysterically laughing. He can't stop laughing. I mean, it's egging Michael on. He's laughing. Everyone seems to have turned a corner.
Michael is very good at roasting, I guess. And Michael has a talking head that wraps up the whole moment. He says,
Boom。Roasted。克里德，你的牙齿打电话来了。你的口气臭死了。Boom。Roasted。安吉拉。安吉拉在哪？哦，你在那儿。我没看见你，在那粒米后面。Boom。Roasted。斯坦利，你在做爱时压死了你的妻子，而且你的心脏烂透了。Boom。Roasted。奥斯卡，你是。同性恋。Boom，roasted。安迪，康奈尔大学打电话来了。他们觉得你烂透了，而且你比奥斯卡还娘。Boom，roasted。好吧，现在斯坦利在咯咯笑。歇斯底里地大笑。他停不下来。我是说，他在怂恿迈克尔。他在笑。每个人似乎都转变了态度。迈克尔很擅长吐槽，我想。迈克尔有个采访总结了整个时刻。他说，
They say that laughter is the best medicine.
So Stanley, you can throw away those pills.
You are cured.
Actually, you know what?
You better hold on to those pills just in case.
Well, lady, I had a lot of fun looking at the candy bag alternates for this as well.
Oh, what do you got?
Oh, okay.
人们说笑是最好的良药。所以斯坦利，你可以扔掉那些药丸了。你被治愈了。其实，你知道吗？你最好还是留着那些药丸以防万一。好吧，女士，我也很享受看这些糖果袋的备选方案。哦，你有什么？哦，好的。
So first of all, with a lot of characters, they had a lot of roastable things.
Your character of Angela Martin, every roast is a spin on hiding behind a grain of rice.
Everyone.
It was so funny to me.
They clearly came up with that idea, I couldn't see you behind that grain of rice.
And they were like, that's it.
We're not going to do better than that.
Because there were some slight alternates, but it always ended with, oh, I'm sorry,
所以首先，对于很多角色，他们有很多可以吐槽的点。你的角色安吉拉·马丁，每一个吐槽都是关于躲在一粒米后面。每一个。这对我来说太搞笑了。他们显然想出了那个点子，我看不见你躲在那粒米后面。他们就觉得，就是这个了。我们做不出比这更好的了。因为有一些轻微的备选，但总是以“哦，抱歉，
I couldn't see you behind that grain of rice, which was very funny to me.
Here are a few of the alternates that stood out to me.
Oh, Pam, did you not hear me through that dirty mop you call hair?
Boom, roasted.
Oh, my God.
And this one.
They say people tend to be attracted to people who look like themselves.
So I don't know what happened with Jim and Pam.
我没看见你躲在那粒米后面”结尾，这对我来说非常有趣。这里有几个让我印象深刻的备选。哦，帕姆，你没听见我透过你那头脏拖把一样的头发说话吗？Boom，roasted。哦，天哪。还有这个。人们倾向于被和自己长得像的人吸引。所以我不知道吉姆和帕姆发生了什么。
Their kid's going to look like a pair of stilts with boobs.
Have fun giving birth to that, Pam.
Boom, roasted.
This is my favorite.
There's a whole page of Toby Boom Roasted.
Oh, my gosh.
But they are all just Michael telling him to F off and that he hates him.
Here's an example, in all caps.
他们的孩子看起来会像一对长着胸部的踩高跷的人。祝你生出那个孩子时玩得开心，帕姆。Boom，roasted。这是我最喜欢的。有一整页关于托比的Boom Roasted。哦，天哪。但它们全都是迈克尔叫他滚蛋，说他讨厌他。这里有个例子，全大写。
Toby, fuck you. I hope you die. Boom roasted. That's it.
Well, the episode's going to end with our movie, Mrs. Albert Hannity.
And it's a real surprise ending. Yeah. Big twist at the end.
Twist. Jack Black is Sam. He's returning to Lily's house played by Cloris. He's got flowers and a walking cane in his hand.
Yeah. He's running up to the front door. As he gets there, he looks through the window.
So she's with another man, another young man.
Yeah, and they are in the throes of fashion.
It's very, very, very much of a love scene.
托比，去死吧。我希望你死。Boom roasted。就是这样。好吧，这一集将以我们的电影《阿尔伯特·汉尼蒂夫人》结束。这是一个真正的惊喜结局。对。最后有个大反转。反转。杰克·布莱克饰演萨姆。他回到了莉莉的家，由克洛里斯饰演。他手里拿着花和一根拐杖。对。他跑向大门。当他到达时，他透过窗户往里看。她和另一个男人在一起，另一个年轻男人。对，他们正处于激情之中。这非常、非常、非常像是一场爱情戏。
It's a makeout.
It's a big makeout.
It's a real big makeout.
The man she is making out with is our writer's assistant, Nate Federman.
Nate, we had to know.
How did you get this job?
He sent in this audio clip, and I promise you, you will hang on.
on his every word.
这是一场热吻。这是一场大热吻。真的是一场大热吻。她正在热吻的那个男人是我们的编剧助理内特·费德曼。内特，我们必须知道。你是怎么得到这份工作的？他发来了这段音频片段，我保证，你会听得入迷。
Hi, my name's Nate Federman.
I was one of the writer's assistants on stress relief,
and I got to make out with Chloris Leachman.
And this is my story.
Originally, my part was supposed to be for Zach Efron,
and there were actual lines.
But he turned it down, and so did Corbyn Blue
and Christopher Min's plots.
嗨，我叫内特·费德曼。我是《压力缓解》的编剧助理之一，我有幸和克洛里斯·利奇曼热吻。这就是我的故事。最初，我的角色本应该是扎克·埃夫隆的，而且有实际的台词。但他拒绝了，科尔宾·布鲁和克里斯托弗·明兹-普莱斯也拒绝了。
And the day before it was supposed to shoot,
they hadn't cast it, and all the lines had been cut.
And they really just needed
somebody who was young looking to make out with Cloris Leachman.
They didn't have to be handsome or famous.
So enter me.
Paul Lieberstein and Jeff Blitz, who was directing the episode,
pulled me aside at work and asked me if I was interested in doing the part.
在原定拍摄的前一天，他们还没选好演员，所有的台词都被删了。他们真的只是需要一个看起来年轻的人和克洛里斯·利奇曼热吻。不需要长得帅或出名。所以，我来了。保罗·利伯斯坦和执导这一集的杰夫·布里茨在工作时把我拉到一边，问我是否有兴趣演这个角色。
And I'm not an actor.
The last time I had performed was in fifth grade.
I was muddled the tailor and figler on the roof.
And I froze in the middle of wonder of wonder, miracle of miracles,
and the audience laughed at me.
and it was scarring.
But I was really excited to earn 500 bucks and residuals.
So I said, sure, I'll do it.
我不是演员。我上次表演还是在五年级。我演了《屋顶上的提琴手》里的裁缝莫德尔。我在唱“奇迹中的奇迹”时僵住了，观众嘲笑我。这留下了心理创伤。但我真的很兴奋能赚500美元和重播费。所以我说，当然，我愿意。
At the time, I was so terrified of letting the show down.
I was working with all these incredible actors and actresses
who actually knew what they were doing,
and I just didn't want to screw things up for everybody.
So I went home that night,
and I told my girlfriend, now my wife,
about what I was going to have to do.
And I was really scared.
当时，我非常害怕让剧组失望。我和所有这些真正知道自己在做什么的杰出男女演员一起工作，我只是不想把事情搞砸。所以我那天晚上回家，告诉了我女朋友，也就是现在的妻子，我要做什么。我真的很害怕。
So I practiced with her,
and I didn't get much sleep that night.
And then I woke up early the next day and I arrived on location and I was just terrified because I was so out of my element.
And I'm in hair and makeup and they're doing my hair.
And all of a sudden I feel these hands running through my hair.
And I hear this voice go, I hear that you and I are going to be doing some kissing with her.
And I turn around and it's Cloris Leachman.
And she's smiling at me.
所以我跟她练习，那天晚上我没怎么睡。第二天我早早醒来，到达外景地，我简直吓坏了，因为我完全不在状态。我在做发型和化妆，他们正在帮我弄头发。突然我感觉到有双手穿过我的头发。我听到一个声音说，我听说你和我待会儿要接吻。我转过身，是克洛里斯·利奇曼。她正对着我笑。
And I'm like, yeah, we're going to be doing the scene together.
So then we go to the actual set, and I'm riding in a van with Cloris Leachman and Jack Black and Jessica Alba.
And these are, you know, big-name stars, and I'm the writer's assistant on the office and so out of my element.
And I'm just desperate not to seem like a total hack and screw things up for everyone.
So eventually, it's time for the kissing scene with Cloris.
and we're positioned on a couch, and she's sitting on my lap, and I have my arms around her,
and we're talking, and it's very pleasant, and she's very nice, and she's telling you about her children.
But then right before we do the actual take, she gets real serious, you know, she's getting into character,
我说，是的，我们要一起拍这场戏。然后我们去了真正的片场，我和克洛里斯·利奇曼、杰克·布莱克还有杰西卡·阿尔芭坐在一辆面包车里。这些都是大牌明星，而我是《办公室》的编剧助理，完全不在状态。我拼命不想让自己看起来像个彻底的菜鸟，把事情搞砸。终于，到了和克洛里斯的吻戏时间，我们坐在沙发上，她坐在我腿上，我搂着她，我们在聊天，气氛很愉快，她很友善，在跟我讲她的孩子们。但在我们正式开拍前，她变得非常严肃，你知道，她进入了角色，
and she looks me in the eye, and I'll never forget this.
And she goes, when they call action, I want you to grab my ass and really get up in the crack.
So when they called action, I grabbed her ass and I really got up in that crack.
And we did the scene.
We shot it many times.
They had to get it from a lot of different angles.
So we ended up making out quite a bit.
She did say a variety of other pretty raunchy things.
她看着我的眼睛，我永远不会忘记这一点。她说，当他们喊Action时，我要你抓住我的屁股，真的深入到缝里去。所以当他们喊Action时，我抓住了她的屁股，真的深入到了那个缝里。我们拍了这场戏。我们拍了很多次。他们必须从很多不同的角度拍摄。所以我们最后吻了相当长的时间。她确实说了各种各样相当下流的话。
She's an expert at Dirty Talk.
But it was an amazing experience.
And I'm incredibly grateful that my five seconds of fame were spent with an absolute legend like
Clarus Leachman.
And it's something that I always get a kick out of when I get to tell people.
Nate, thank you.
Thank you for sharing your story.
I mean, what an amazing story.
她是说脏话的专家。但这真是一次奇妙的经历。我非常感激我那五秒钟的名声是和克洛里斯·利奇曼这样的绝对传奇一起度过的。每当我告诉别人这件事时，我总是觉得很有趣。内特，谢谢你。谢谢你分享你的故事。我是说，多么奇妙的故事。
Amazing.
Hey, Nate.
Zach Efron isn't available.
What are you doing tomorrow?
Yeah.
Can you do something for me real quick?
Sure.
What is it?
太棒了。嘿，内特。扎克·埃夫隆没空。你明天有空吗？对。你能帮我个忙吗？当然。是什么？
It's just that scene where you make a lot of.
out with Cloris Leachman.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Sure.
I guess so.
And you get $500.
就是那场你和克洛里斯·利奇曼热吻的戏。嗯哼。对。哦，好的。当然。我想可以。而且你有500美元。
Yeah.
And a great story.
And a story for your lifetime.
Yes.
You know what?
In these kind of over-the-top moments, you have to go for it.
And Cloris was saying, sweetie, I give you permission to go for it.
You grab my butt.
对。还有一个很棒的故事。一个让你受用终身的故事。是的。你知道吗？在这些夸张的时刻，你必须豁出去。克洛里斯当时说，亲爱的，我允许你豁出去。你抓我的屁股。
Sell it.
That's what the scene needs.
And we can't be shy with each other.
Yeah.
We have to go for it.
And I've been in situations with actors where we've given one another permission.
Yeah.
And it's so helpful because it gets you out of your head and you're like, okay, good.
演出来。这就是这场戏需要的。我们不能害羞。对。我们必须豁出去。我和演员们在一起时，我们曾互相给予许可。对。这非常有帮助，因为它让你不再胡思乱想，你会觉得，好的，很好。
Now we can just play the scene.
Have fun with it.
I mean, you guys watch every single Dwight and Angela make out.
Exactly.
Sometimes you just got to go for it.
And on our set, I think we were so good about being like, okay, I'm cool with this.
You do this.
We're fine.
现在我们可以尽情演这场戏了。玩得开心。我是说，你们看了每一场德怀特和安吉拉的热吻。没错。有时你就是得豁出去。在我们的片场，我觉得我们很擅长沟通，比如，好的，我对此没问题。你这样做。我们没问题。
You know, we communicated.
And I have to imagine you're with this legend, performance.
Chloris Leachman.
I'd be timid.
Yes, you've never met this person.
Yeah.
So for her to just be so fun and up for it like that and to just say, do it, baby, do it.
I love it.
你知道，我们沟通了。我得想象一下你和这位传奇表演者在一起。克洛里斯·利奇曼。我会很胆怯。是的，你从没见过这个人。对。所以她能如此有趣，如此乐在其中，只是说，做吧，宝贝，做吧。我喜欢。
Yeah.
Well, there you have it.
Stress relief.
Part two, do you feel less stressed?
Have you had some relief of your stress after listening to this podcast, everyone?
I hope so.
I hope her podcast doesn't stress people out.
If we can leave anything with you from stress relief other than boom roasted, it's
对。好吧，这就是《压力缓解》。第二部分，你感觉压力小了吗？听完这个播客，大家压力缓解了吗？我希望如此。我希望她的播客不会让人感到压力。如果说除了“Boom roasted”之外，我们能从《压力缓解》中带给你们什么，那就是
Staying alive, staying alive, staying alive.
Ah, ah, ah, stay in alive.
Oh my God, that was, now people are stressed.
We relieve their stress and then we gave it right back.
I'm so sorry.
Start over.
Start the podcast again.
Bye, you guys.
Staying alive, staying alive, staying alive. Ah, ah, ah, stay in alive. 哦天哪，那，现在人们压力大了。我们缓解了他们的压力，然后又把压力还给了他们。我很抱歉。重新开始。重新开始播客吧。再见，伙计们。
Have a great week.
We'll see you next week.
For lecture circuit.
Part one.
I can't wait.
I have so many stories.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
祝你们有愉快的一周。我们下周见。讲座巡回。第一部分。我等不及了。我有很多故事。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton.
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。